Luffy's crazy sun god Destiny revealed
the shocking end of Kuma's backstory and
the hype return to Egghead and more
happen in this insane chapter so make
sure to stay tuned for that Chan the
pirate king within and smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing one piece
reviews like this one I want to keep
them coming make this the video you join
the Knock Out by subscribing so you
don't miss future reviews and updates
you're also helping us get closer to our
insane goal of 2 million subscribers
here on YouTube and now without further
Ado let's jump into It spoilers and all
so we left off last chapter with the
absolutely insane moment where kid
Bonnie took out a skilled Cipher pole
agent using the move distorted future
which changed everything and revealed
she had one of the most broken devil
fruits in the series if not the most
broken let me know your thoughts on the
most broken fruit in the series but
think about how crazy this one is using
distorted future she could create a Naik
future for herself and by doing so she
can manifest the power of the mythical
Zone NAA fruit she uses an attack
similar to Luffy's gear three and the
giant pumped up arm knocks Alpha out and
and after she kept those letters from
Kuma and made Bonnie D Kuma's love that
punch could not have been more
satisfying so despite the fact that
she's young Bonnie is already
established as a very strong character
with even stronger potential so
accordingly this chapter starts with
Bonnie's Journey after escaping from
alpha the now Bonnie Pirates were
traveling to an island searching for
Kuma and he was there but sadly when the
Bonnie Pirates arrive Kuma has already
warped away Kuma is aware that Bonnie is
looking for him but he decides that he
can't meet her after all that would be
putting her life in danger we're then
told a detail I love it said that
because the Bonnie Pirates always left
tons of injured kids and elderly after
their attacks they were believed to be
really evil Pirates of course though we
know that this was Bonnie's agef fruit
at work and the so-called kids and
Elders were actually Marines transformed
by Bonnie's Powers so from the sound of
this it seems like Bonnie's powers can
last for quite a long time so that does
also support the idea that Oda may make
her use her abilities on Luffy if he
needs a power boost at some point in the
future turning him into Prime Luffy we
already saw a similar thing with Momo so
seeing a prime Luffy in gear 5 is
looking more and more possible then when
you consider what kind of distorted
future upgrades she could add things
just get beyond crazy again definitely a
strong Contender for most broken devil
fruit for a single fighter but even more
so if you had it on a crew # Bonny for
straw hat we then cut to Luffy as we
know Kuma has also been keeping an eye
on Luffy and his progress knowing he's
dragon's son before we saw a 16-year-old
Luffy practicing gum gum battle axe the
move he used to eventually beat arlong
which was such an awesome moment to get
and now we see when Luffy got his first
Bounty I got to say this really reminds
me of some time travel in fiction that
I've seen in a good way even like the
Christmas carol for example where
someone just travels back in time and
sees all this stuff from their past of
course this isn't actually time travel
for Kuma but it feels the same because
we saw all of these moments before and
now through Kuma we are revisiting them
from this new vantage point and I love
it it not only reminds me of these epic
moments again but it lets us appreciate
them more knowing everything we know now
we also see Ace jimbe and sabo's
reactions as well after that during the
eny lobby incident Kuma visits Vega punk
in egad Island Vega punk shows him an
army of pacifist that's being produced
and they talk about the eny lobby
incident keep in mind Dragon told Kuma
not to talk about Luffy because a child
is a parent weakness as he said but he
does tell Vega Punk since Vega Punk will
find out either way through his memories
thus it's useless to hide Mega Punk for
his part can't believe Luffy is dragon's
son now Luffy is special to him since
he's obviously close to his father
Dragon 2o I love how Oda just keeps
flushing out all these character
Dynamics and relationships even though
we've been hearing about vegapunk for so
long and Luffy just met him it turns out
they actually were connected and had
history in multiple ways and we got a
similar thing with Kuma who would have
thought this character would be so deep
and lovable when he was first introduced
anyways Kuma said says it's curious how
a boy with rubber Powers is going
against the world government just like
the legendary NAA and Vega Punk laughs
saying that's true so already Kuma is
touching on Luffy sun god Destiny but it
will get much more specific and much
crazier later on we then jump to the
Thriller bark incident and we see it
from Kuma's point of view in other words
Kuma sees a straw head crew fighting
Moria and after the incident Kuma
receives a denen Mushi call with the
order to prepare for war against
Whitebeard we then cut to sabod where
both Bond B and Luffy are so Kuma's
interest intersect here it makes sense
he'd be here we see Bonnie's intro scene
again and now we discover that Kuma was
actually hiding outside the restaurant
looking at Bonnie through a window and
smiling Kuma says she has grown into a
strong pirate and although he doesn't
want to meet her and risk her safety
even more it's nice that he appeared to
be watching over her as long as he could
Kuma then hears about the incident with
the SL Dragon he warps to the human
auction roof immediately and looks
inside Kuma is shocked when he discovers
that Luffy punched a Celestial Dragon to
protect a Fishman who are even viewed as
being below humans in the world
government status hierarchy part of me
just wants to rewatch one piece so I can
be like oh yeah so Kuma was there
watching at this moment for every one of
these moments also if I watch with a one
piece virsion meaning someone who's
never watched one piece before I can
just think to myself haha you have no
idea Kuma is watching this or even who
he is but yeah we totally do have a one
piece version podcast so check that out
Link in the description anyways I love a
says here he says about Luffy punching
the world Noble this is a rebellious act
that no one has been able to do for
centuries for Kuma it seems with every
new time he sees Luffy he's given more
evidence that this guy is like NAA the
warrior of Liberation and once again it
emphasizes how big of a deal that punch
actually was how it shocked the world of
One Piece also I must say don't you
think it's time for the man who
committed this rebellious act as Kuma
calls it to join forces with the
Revolutionary Army the most rebellious
of organizations come on Oda stop
teasing it and just have dragon show up
at Egghead already Dragon should want to
help Bonnie for Kuma's sake as well not
just Luffy then we see the sabot
incident AKA kizaru sentomaru and the
pacifistas versus the straw hats but
this time from Kuma's point of view we
get to the point where Luffy is
shattered he says I couldn't save them
not a single one of my nak Kuma thinks
to himself that that's not true at all
they all just aren't ready yet for the
new world he says do not come until you
are ready because you you are a man who
might one day save the world end quote
and so yes we finally come to the point
where in black and white even Luffy the
guy who seem to always just do his own
thing and not care about being labeled
the good guy is being positioned as the
person that's s to save the world here
now is that kind of predictable for a
battle shown in manga yes but I respect
in the sense that saving the world just
seems to be a byproduct of Luffy being
Luffy he's not like I'm going to save
the world he's just going to end up
accidentally doing it so to speak while
pursuing his own dreams now the Egghead
island in the Flash back and Saturn
orders Vega Punk to put an additional
self-destruct switch on Kuma just in
case Vega Punk tries in vain to
negotiate for other methods that will
allow Kuma to retain his Consciousness
but Saturn insists on his mind being
wiped and he says something very
important here he says I'm also a
scientist it's useless to try to lie to
me Vega Punk end quote now yes we did
know that he was titled the warrior God
of Science and defense but still knowing
he's an actual Bonafide scientist as
well makes a lot of sense and also
explains why he's playing such a big
role here during Vega Punk's arc on the
last day of his normal Free Will life
just before the Paramount War Kuma and
Vega Punk say goodbye to each other Vega
Punk programmed Kuma to fight the
Whitebeard pirates in the war but also
Kuma asked VAP Punk to program him to
protect the Thousand Sunny too Kuma says
he would love to see straw Hat's growth
but since he can't do it at least he
wants to protect their home Mega Punk
finally asks Kuma why do you have so
much faith in Luffy and Kuma says I know
NAA is just a legend but I promised
Bonnie that one day a warri of
Liberation will come to free her Luffy's
actions moved me I think he's a man who
might end up changing the Seas one day
wow this is amazing so Kuma pretty much
situates Luffy as nikah here which works
perfectly since he ate that fruit but
also it sets up the present events
perfectly as literally NAA is about to
free Bonnie and of course as Kuma says
eventually change the Seas out of all
people Kuma chose to bet on Luffy and he
definitely made the right bet Kuma then
gives his memory to Vega punk as
promised his memories though are like a
copy of the original one so Kuma doesn't
forget anything by pulling it out with
his powers also the memory will
disappear when someone touches it so
Vega Punk develops the system to observe
and study it without touching the memory
sphere itself and I got to say if Kuma's
memories could be duplicated like this
then what's to say that Vega Punk didn't
find a way to store them before Bonnie
touched them or what if Kuma could
extract a copy of something else too
like his soul or something there are a
lot of possibilities so I wouldn't count
Kuma out just yet like I said my dude
deserves a happy ending after after
everything he's been through at the very
least let him be inside the ancient
robot AKA The Iron Giant anyways as Kuma
pulls out his memories in the flashback
we see Kuma's entire life flashing
before him and all the faces of the
people he loved including his dad his
mom Ivano of Jenny and of course Bonnie
then in a very emotional scene we see
Vega Punk pulling a machine's lever in
tears totally reminds me of a
Frankenstein creating Frankenstein's
monster kind of situation here but
obviously more emotional the machine
starts to erase Kuma's consciousness
there are rays of light shining on
Egghead just like in Kuma's church when
he took damage from people all of the
scientists and saru are praying and
saluting together and getting scientists
to pray is just always an impressive
feat and goes to show how great of a
character and person Kuma was the
flashback then ends and in the niku room
we see that the sphere with Kuma's
memory is gone and Bonnie is crying on
the floor the chapter ends with Kuma's
final words that he asked Vega Punk to
tell Bonnie Kuma says and I quote happy
10th birthday Bonnie end quote and wow
this has got to be one of if not the
best backstories in one piece the way it
fleshed out Kuma's character and set up
the present events is just insane I
never thought I'd care so much about
Kuma but thanks to this masterful
backstory I do Insane goes for Bonnie
and if you enjoyed this one then you
won't want to miss my recent video about
Zoro and sanji's devil fruits link on
screen right now like And subscribe to
help us reach 2 million subscribers here
on YouTube and I'll see you in the next
one